Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to turn to something we haven't
talked about so far in this class.
As you look at the journey we've come
through, we looked at technical analysis
and charting. We looked at value
investing, growth investing, arbitrage,
trading on information.
But in every one of these, we focused in
individual stocks, individual
investments. In this session, I want to
focus on market timing. Why so many
people are drawn to it and why it's so
difficult to succeed. I call it the
impossible dream drawing on a Broadway
show. But it is a dream that almost
every investor has. I'd be lying if I
said I don't try to time markets. In
fact, anybody who claims that they never
time markets is lying because the draw
of market timing is so great that
everybody at some point in time in their
investing life does a wee bit of market
timing. So let's see where market timing
fits in the portfolio process.
You remember I talked about the three
steps of devising a portfolio. The first
is asset allocation. deciding what
percentage of your wealth goes into
stocks and bonds and real assets and you
can expand that out into geographies and
sectors. The broad asset allocation
decision. The second step is what we
call stock selection, investment
selection. Which stocks, which bonds,
which real real assets should you hold?
And the third part is execution.
Market timing is all about the asset
allocation part of the portfolio
management process. And here's how it
plays out. We talked about how as
investors based on our risk aversion, we
make a judgment of how much money to put
into different asset classes. So let's
say that you're in your mid30s and you
have a long time horizon. You're willing
to take risk and you say I put my 60% of
my money in stocks, 30% in bonds, and
10% in real estate. Fair enough. That is
an asset allocation bas based on your
risk aversion, your age, and what you
what your liquidity needs are. Here's
where market timing comes in. Let's
assume you think markets are overpriced.
In particular, stocks are overpriced,
but you believe bonds are underpriced.
Here's what you would do. Rather than
put 60% of your money into stocks, you
might put only 40 or 20 or even 0% and
increase the amount you have in bonds.
So market timing is about moving away
from that asset allocation mix that's
the right one given your risk aversion
but doing it because you think a
particular market stocks or bonds or
real assets is underpriced or
overpriced. Now within each of these
broad asset classes you can do further
market timing within stocks for instance
you can decide US stocks are overpriced
but European stocks are underpriced. So
what do you do? You overload on European
stocks more than you normally own and
and underload on US stocks. So market
timing is all about changing your asset
allocation.
You're saying why do people try? The
reason is very simple. If you can time
markets, the amount of returns you can
make will vastly be vastly greater than
the returns you will make by picking
individual stocks. In 1986 article that
drew a lot of attention, a group of
researchers looked at what percentage of
the variation in quarterly performance
across active investors is explained by
asset allocation 94%.
Most of the differences came not from
the individual stocks they picked but
from the allocated how much money they
decide to put in the stock market. A
later study looked at mutual funds and
pension funds and concluded that about
40% of the difference in returns came
from their asset allocation decisions.
Asset allocation has a disproportionate
effect on your overall returns. So over
the last 20 years, you had 90% of your
money and you're a US investor, you 90%
of your money in T- bills or T- bonds,
you would have significantly
underperformed the market even though
you might have picked the the best bonds
during that period. Now, if you dig a
little deeper and look further at what
what draws us to market timing, here are
some very simple statistics as to why
you and I are going to be tempted by
market timing. You know, when you watch
the stock market in across time and you
have good years and bad years, good days
and bad days, good weeks and bad weeks.
Let's play a little experiment. Let's
assume that you could stay out of the
bad days, the bad weeks or the bad
years. your returns are going to be much
much greater than somebody who couldn't
do that, right? And in hindsight, it's
going to look obvious. So, you're going
to look back and say, "I knew that crash
was coming." Notice after every big
correction, people claim they knew. I
should have got out before. So, in
hindsight, it looks like if you time
markets, you'd have been you'd be much
better off today. And if you dig a
little deeper, there will always be
indicators that seem to point to that
market correction, those bad days, and
you say, "If only I'd use those
indicators." Those indicators might have
been, you know, we and we'll go through
a whole series. Might be macroeconomic
indicators. They might be technical
indicators. They might be feelood
indicators, but indicators that told you
that a correction was coming.
In fact, there have been studies that
looked at what your returns would look
like as an investor if you just avoided
the bad days, the bad weeks, or the bad
years. One study looked at what would
happen if you avoided the 10 worst days
of the year, concluded you'd almost
double your returns. In 1992, Schilling
Schiller Schilling examined the effect
of on your annual returns of being able
to stay out of the market during bad
months, not just bad days, bad months.
And he concluded that an investor who
would have missed the 50 weakest months
between 46 and 91 would almost again
double their returns. Other studies
reinforce this findings. Staying out of
the worst days, the worst weeks, the
worst months would clearly have this
supercharging effect on returns. And if
you look back in time and you think
about the bubbles, the dot bubble, the
2008 correction, you say, "If only I'd
stayed out of that bubble, look how much
better off I'd have been." That is the
draw of market timing. If only if only
if only becomes the the the the
recurring thing.
But there's a cost, right? We talked
about the 10 worst days. But one of the
things about markets, it's intero
interspersed between the worst days is
often some of the best days in the
market. So as you try to miss the worst
days of the market, what if you start
missing the best days? And it turns out
that if you miss the 10 best days of the
market, you can have your return. So
here's the challenge. In trying to miss
the worst days in the market, are you
also missing the best days? In trying to
miss the worst months, are you also
missing the best months?
So it turns out that
and in fact that's the it gives rise to
the thing it's better to spend time in
the market than timing the market
because many people in trying to time
the market end up being out of the
market.
Now, it goes without saying that if you
try to time the market, you're going to
turn over your portfolio a lot more,
right? You got to sell things and buy
things, that's going to increase your
transactions cost. Often, you're trading
much more than somebody who doesn't do
market timing. And if you trade, and we
saw that in earlier session on taxes,
you're also going to increase your tax
libraries. If you think markets are
overpriced today and you sell all your
stocks and even if you get the timing
right, remember when you sell all your
stocks, assuming that you've held them
for a while, you're going to have tax
liabilities that come due when you sell
the stock. So that's the trade-off you
face. There's a benefit, there's a cost.
We look at whether the net effect pays
off for people, but that's what drives
the desired time markets. Now, we talked
a lot about timing in the stock market.
You can time the bond market as well,
right? How does it what form does this
take? When you talk about the direction
of interest rates that interest rates
are going to come down over the next two
or three or four years, especially
long-term rates, you're telling me bonds
are a good place to be because when
interest rates come down, bond prices go
up. Conversely, we think interest rates
are going to go up. Bond prices are
going to go down, especially the
long-term bonds.
Timing in the real estate market, we all
do it, right? You own a house which you
bought in a particular year. You say,
"If only I had bought it three years
earlier or 5 years earlier, I would have
been much better off." If you bought
when the market was high and with
collectibles and other assets, this has
become a recurring theme. You take
something like Bitcoin, trading at close
to $100,000 when I'm doing this session
right now, and you say, "If only I'd put
my money in Bitcoin 10 years ago rather
than stocks or bonds, think of how much
wealthier I'd have been."
Hindsight is 2020 and looking back in
time, it looks like we could have made a
lot more money by timing these markets.
But what we're missing there is the
shifting fundamentals that at that point
in time in 2014,
you didn't know what was coming. And if
you think about your cho choices then,
you could have made some bad choices
based on looking at the things you
looked at.
Cycles are unpredictable. Transaction
costs are very high. But basically
people try to time markets because the
payoff looks so high.
Now in the next few sessions we're going
to talk about how people try to time
markets. Let me at least list out the
choices. There are people who use
non-financial indicators. You think what
does that mean? That they're indicators
that don't show up in the numbers and
we'll talk about a few. There are of
course technical indicators. We talked
about these in the context of trading
individual stocks charts trading volume.
technical indicators that might tell you
where the overall market is going.
There's a whole group of indicators that
I call mean reversion indicators where
you invest in something because you
think things are going to revert back to
the way they used to be. Mean remember
the example I gave with interest rates
just a couple of minutes ago. How do
people decide that interest rates are
going to go up or down? They often based
on what interest rates have been
historically
between in the last decade for instance
the rates were low 2% 2 and a half% 3%
there were people who were convinced
rates would go up why not because of any
fundamental analysis but because they
remember to time when rates were five or
6% that they've got to go back higher
there are people who try to time markets
using macroeconomic indicators and at
its basis you can see that makes sense
after all markets reflect economy
So if I can forecast what the economy is
going to do that's going to strengthen
or weaken I should be able to make money
out in the market. Maybe maybe not. And
finally we talked about valuation in
earlier in earlier sessions as a basis
for deciding what stocks to buy
undervalued versus overvalued. I'm going
to argue that you can bring in the same
tools of valuation to markets to do an
intrinsic valuation
of all stocks to decide whether stocks
collectively are cheap or expensive,
whether interest rates are going to
decline or increase and whether real
assets are headed up or down. So there's
a lot on our table on the table. We look
at the variety of choices and why after
looking even at the variety we may
decide not to time markets. So in
summary, everybody tries to time
markets. Very few people succeed.
We look at what makes market timing
difficult in the aggregate,
but it's something to bring into your
arsenal when you think about different
investment philosophies.
I hope you found the session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.